[музика]
торгова бригада Нацгвардії буревій є
частиною Гвардії наступ у сформованої
міністерством внутрішніх справ України
для зміцнення збройних сил ця бригада
постала на базі першої бригади
оперативного призначення Національної
Гвардії в України всі 9 бригад Гвардії
наступу створені на базі підрозділів що
вже мають бойовий досвід вони додатково
укомплектовані новобранцями в перші дні
літа на полігон для вишколу виїхав
батальйон оперативного призначення імені
Генерала Сергія Кульчицького що
нещодавно увійшов до складу бригади
буревій
На сьогоднішньому занятті
відпрацьовували стріляння з різних
положень стріляння з укриття після чого
зміни магазинів перезарядки можливі
усунення затримок а також відпрацювання
стрільби у двійках зі зміною положень зі
зміною укриттів кулеметиків тренують
використовувати рух і рельєф місцевості
для ефективного знищення ворога і
захисту власного життя інструктор оцінив
виконання завдань на чеку
якщо ти кулеметник ти пріоритетна ціль
на полі бою і звичайно противник буде
зосереджуватися в вагоні тому ти повинен
бути
підготовлений фізично морально і ти маєш
швидко вчасно змінювати свою позицію
тобто відпрацював будь добрий міняє
позицію Якщо ви хочете загинути
під час навчань нещадно палить сонце
температура вище 30 градусів але бійці
мусять і далі тренуватися в повному
спорядженні
інструктори вимогли їй карають промахи
присіданнями і віджиманнями
ні ми не прицілюємось в яблучко у
динаміці щоразу намагаємося напрацювати
дедалі більше точність Хто розуміє про
що йдеться той знає що в динаміці не так
просто стріляти під час перебіжок а так
тільки одне прагнемо цілий час до
кращого
стремимся
інструктори що тренують гвардію наступу
пройшли підготовку в НАТО де закордонні
спеціалісти навчали їх тонкощім
військової справи дідівщини на полігоні
непомітно
особовий склад у нас складається з
більшості досвідчених бійців але до нас
дуже багато приходе новобранці які
бажають проходити службу в нашій бригаді
в нашому підрозділі Вони стають в один з
три з нашими старими воїнами і
розпочинає процес підготовки і
підтягується інструктора пройшли або
підготовку в НАТО дуже багато
закордонних відрядження особового складу
там де їх спеціалісти НАТО підготовлюють
на їхній техніці на нашій техніці
озброєні це все акумулюється досвід і
переноситься сюди на поле боя нас як
такої проблематики там молоді старі там
бійці і взагалі немає старші щось учать
молодших
ми можемо тоже там дещо його навчитися
коли ви є спільне родини то в нас там
старики там начинають розказувати
показувати як той самий тепловізором
користуватися як користуватися там
якимось там іншими там приборами там які
здають там поради там розказують про
свій бойовий досвід тому що ну при цьому
бажанні ну всьо інструктора навчити не
можуть тому що це ну в такі терміни саме
нереально бригада буревій є штурмовою
одне з її головних завдань прорив
оборони ворога тому бійців навчають
поводженню з різноманітами видами зброї
на цьому занятті був вишкіл зі стрільби
з підствольних та ручних гранатометів
тим часом на іншому полігоні
відпрацьовували навички бригадні
артилеристи у них на озброєнні натовські
гаубиці торнадо прийшов у бригаду
буревій стероборони збройних сил і не
шкодує про цей крок з того що я бачив
вартість
Де я маю честь
служити народу України зараз це
кадрові військові які набагато краще нас
навчають за той час що я тут нас навчали
дуже з різних сторон артилерійська
інженерна забезпечення артилерійських
підрозділів
як будова гармат ми їх розбирали збирали
проходили курс такий базовий але
різносторонній кожен день У нас є графік
навчання і кожен день ми навчаємось
Після навчання у нас є практичні заняття
бойовий медик Іван перший рік
повномасштабної війни залишався в
тиловому підрозділі але зрештою
перевівся до батальйону імені
Кульчицького бо це бойовий батальйон
який виконує бойові задачі на сході на
півдні я для себе вирішив що
відсиджуватись в село то трошки не моє
треба прийняти її
активну участь в бойових діях в складі
підрозділу які Як бачите він навчається
нас проходять навчання регулярно да нас
вчать нас Тобто ми не сидимо там на
позиції і чого чекаємо
І я розумію що рано чи пізно ми все одно
прийдеться їхати все одно прийдеться
захищати неньку Україну І тому я для
себе обрав варіант навчання для того щоб
мати більше знань більше багаж знань
вмінь і їхати з бойовими хлопцями в нас
є інструктора які підготовлені за
натовськими стандартними і вони нам вже
передають свій досвід завдання Івана
евакуація поранених з поля бою і
передача їх парамедикам водночас він є
таким же бійцем як і решта опановує
навички володіння стрілецької зброєю
одна з функцій бойового медика стежити
Щоб усіх бійців були індивідуальні
аптечки вони укомплектовані за
натовським протоколом мерч
турнікет
вдягається на кінцівки для зупинення
кровотечі тут у нас є
оклюзійні наліпки які використовуються
для заклеєння дірок
брюшні порожнині коли
виникає проблема з диханням у людини
бінг стерильний використовувався для
тампонади ран або перев'язки
так називаємо ізраїльський бандаж це
така штукенція да використовується для
перемотки перебинтовки для зупинки
кровотечі так називаємо npa це трубочка
яка вставляється в ніс для того щоб
забезпечити прохідність дихальних шляхів
Коли людина втрачає свідомість
одноразові рукавички
Гемостатик
перев'язувальний гемостатичний який
зупиняє кровотечу Він працює
намокає розбухає і заклеює умовно кажучи
рано
тут у нас є ковдра термоковдра
обов'язково Коли людина втрачає кров
його треба забезпечити йому тепло тут у
нас є спеціальні ножиці якими ми
зрізаємо одяг для того щоб краще нам
бачити яка травма де вона характер тої
травми і так далі досвідчені бійці
батальйону імені Кульчицького кажуть що
раніше в них була спеціалізація на
бойових діях у лісах та містах нині вони
відпрацьовують вміння воювати на
відкритих ділянках місцевості
взаємодіяти з дронами і навчається
навичкам володіння зброєю важкої піхоти
але командир батальйону чорний заявив що
головним для кожного бійця добровольця є
бойовий настрій і розуміння того хто є
ворогом І що робити для якнайшвидшого
завершення війни